johnny depp cuddles up to a badger at a
wildlife rescue just one day after
winning his defamation trial against
amber hurd has mr depp proven by a
greater weight of the evidence
that question the statement was made or
published by ms heard
answer yes the folly wildlife rescue
center in kent england shared this photo
of johnny on facebook holding a badger
according to the organization he toured
the hospital's care and vet units and
was incredibly complementary of the
sanctuary and its staff in the caption
they gushed with excitement writing
guess who's been to see us at folly
wildlife rescue no you're not seeing
things that's the real johnny depp if
i've gained some degree of success in
this industry i'm really it's it's been
it's been very it's been very good to me
and it's been very good for me the
rescue org explains they allowed johnny
the rare privilege of holding freddie an
orphan badger cub who was named after
queen front man freddie mercury they add
in the caption i think it's fair to say
he was bowled over by the whole
experience as for the reason behind
johnny's visit well it was a
recommendation by the orcs patron rocker
jeff beck of course johnny's been making
surprise appearances throughout the
guitarist uk tour johnny depp gives
surprise performance at jeff beck
concert
[Music]
that's johnny at jeff's show on sunday
joining the musician to perform a cover
of marvin gaye's what's going on
[Music]
and on thursday he arrived at another
show marking his third appearance when i
was a kid all i dreamed about was
becoming a famous rock star or you know
this i don't know
this great musician johnny's latest
outing comes just one day after winning
his defamation trial against his ex-wife
amber hurd do you find that mr depp has
proven all the elements of defamation
answer yes he was awarded 15 million
dollars in both punitive and
compensatory damages after the jury
decided he was in fact defamed by her
today's verdict confirms what we have
said from the beginning that the claims
against johnny depp are defamatory and
unsupported by any evidence but amber's
lawyer elaine bredhoff told cbs mornings
she's ready to fight back and how is she
today what is her next move she's right
well her next move is appeal there was a
heartbroken she is heartbroken and one
of the first things that she said when
she came back from the verdict when we
went into the conference room was i am
so sorry to all these women that said
that yes she felt like she had let down
all of these women because she had more
evidence than most people do and yet
they still didn't believe her
[Music]